I went back home and I sat down on the
sofa with my mum
and then the local BBC East Midlands
news came on
and they said two men from The Meadows
they've been arrested
on suspicion to murder
and I was just like she was like she
looked at me and said
[Music]
that's not you is it
and that's how she found out
[Music]
obviously we've met you before but for
any new Watchers or listeners can you
just give a brief introduction to
yourself and who you are
my name's Jacob Dunn I'm 30 years old
um I'm an author a father
and campaigner on a few social issues
that are close to my heart Mental Health
mainly men's mental health
um criminal justice
perhaps what I'm most well known for is
for
raising awareness around one punch
after
throwing a punch in 2000 back in 2011
11.
um
which sadly
ended another person's life
well I mean let's get back to the very
beginning of it all like can you just
tell us a little bit about your
childhood what growing up was like
I grew up in um Inner City
neighborhood
um in Nottingham
Council estate called The Meadows
which I love and hate at the same time
your typical kind of upbringing to be
honest I was part of a very loving
family
my mum tried to send me to primary
schools outside of my neighborhood and
through
going to church in other areas and stuff
like that she was able to manage to get
me into a primary school that was
outside of my
the area I grew up in is that because
she didn't want you to go to school in
that area yeah yes right she always kind
of
felt like if I'm going to give him the
best chance
then
I'll try and get him into a school sure
not in that area which she did and
looking back it was a great decision
enjoyed it was kind of just a free
spirit had a good childhood really good
childhood
um
my mum and dad split up
when I was about seven years old
so what's that like year four
Primary School
and um
because everything was so settled in my
routine and I was happier
school or whatever I don't think I
really
paid much attention to it
um although it's quite a messy
divorce unfortunately and I do remember
at times feeling like
I was made to pick a side
um
particularly as a young lad Mommy's boy
it was easy to
take her aside and yeah obviously he was
working a lot
seven days a week a lot of the time as
well so I didn't really have the
strongest
relationship with him anyway uh which
meant that after they got divorced and
he moved back to his
family home area in Manchester
um that I didn't see him again I think
it was about
that's where I'm again at 10 and then
the next time I saw him after that I was
I think it was about 16. um
and was that because your parents
falling out yeah that was just the way
that they'd fallen out and as I said I
was kind of made to feel
a little bit like I had to pick sides
right
um
to the floor on my mom's part
um
and then yeah it was just really messy
like Social Services
not social services but like contact
centers to like build relationships and
like me and Mom would be running away
right and he'd be there like wanting to
see his son and you know me and my mom
would be just like running off or I mean
at that point was it did you did you not
want to meet him did you see at that
point I kind of just felt like this just
it was just too much drama yeah it
hadn't really built up a solid
relationship with him he lived far away
um
so
it was easier at that age to just
continue with my school friends
my mum still like put me in loads of
after school clubs and
activities and stuff and I guess it was
it wasn't until I kind of got into my
teens
that I guess I needed
someone that could
keep me in check a little bit more
around I guess that's when I started to
realize you know I wasn't complaining
because I could
push the boundaries more with my mum and
get away with more you know not going to
school and
skyvin getting in trouble getting
arrested and do you think your dad would
have been more of a firm hand I think my
dad would have just been more like lay
down his expectations more but
unfortunately because he wasn't there he
didn't have the legitimacy and so it
took a very long time for us to kind of
heal that relationship and get to a
point
now where
we can't challenge each other
legitimately and we can
we've built up that trust between us so
yeah it just kind of all went tits up
sure and what age is this now we're just
going into secondary school so about
10. just still quite young yes it's
still quite young right because I see it
even today just that transition from
primary school
to Secondary School
is huge
for any young person because you all you
go from child to teenagers don't you
and all of a sudden maybe you've
got a lot of mobile phone now
you'd have to
you know go out with your mates a bit
more you've got that little bit more
Independence and freedom but what comes
with all that is that social anxiety of
like
wanting to fit in well that's what when
you're that age if you find a thing that
makes you popular yeah you just hit that
button over and over again all right
yeah they like you I like yeah yeah it's
like okay I'll just keep watching joke
but I remember in year seven when one of
the not long into my first year at
Secondary School
and the teacher was like we're gonna
bring you more
and I was petrified right I was like oh
[ __ ]
Oh My lightsaber yeah yeah yeah and um I
was like you know really worried about
what my mum's response was going to be
and then yeah I just realized after that
that I could start pushing the
boundaries more because there wasn't
much because there wasn't really come
back from it yeah much comeback from it
and she was someone who
would often try and make excuses for me
as well
oh gosh really like my son behaving like
that doesn't mean like a player against
the teachers you know what I mean or
so then I just started to become a bit
more manipulative about it and to the
sense of consequences are starting to
yeah the consequences starting to fade
away
I'm becoming a little bit more popular
I'm losing interest in
actually
applying myself
at school
so
just start pushing the boundaries
disrespecting more and more people
once I was aggressive
I was just more of like
wanting to have as much joke as I could
and yeah
um keep pushing the boundaries
and it
just become a very gradual
slope into criminality because
there was generation after generation of
people that have been going to the
school
if you were all on the same trajectory
of
and all and who all had the same
attitude towards education because we
didn't have role models in our state
to look up to that had become lawyers or
had applied themselves and become
doctors or were positive role models in
the community and when you say did you
say that criminality what kind of
criminality are we talking about at that
point
foreign
at that point when I was still in school
I've not quite been kicked out yet it's
um
possession of drugs recreational use of
drugs
um antisocial Behavior
in and out of school bits of Awesome
well really
um just like in a park yeah actually
like you've set up been on fire or
something or I'm just getting chased by
the police and then it just became like
reoccurring because we were getting
chased by the teachers
and then we slowly get kicked out there
and then we're just getting chased by
the police and all of a sudden it's just
this continual game of fighting the
system
but what no one tells you is is that you
have to become a part of it at some
point
or you're just gonna be
marginalized
and kick to the curb
um
and the longer you're in it
the longer you're fighting the system
well I tell young people now is you've
got to play the system you can't just
fight the system because you'll be fine
here forever to you to even the grave
did you say you get kicked out of school
yeah so what what led up to that and
what age was that I got kicked out of
school
end of year nine going to see a 10.
um it wasn't for anything specific it
was just a build up you know they tried
giving me report books
getting it signed by every teacher in
every classroom
like senior members of staff that would
just follow me around no one right yeah
just and at that at that age when that's
happening are you embarrassed about that
or is it kind of badge of honor that
you're the worst one that you know yeah
it is almost like a badge of honor
because you're all like comparing which
one of us has got the the most attention
on it which one's not the most
rules being applied to us and
unfortunately no I used to have all
these meetings my mom would come up to
school in all these meetings and um
they'd all be discussing what I needed
but without me even in the room
so no one was actually saying to you so
no one was actually saying that Jacob
what's the cause of this yeah Behavior
even though I probably wouldn't have
been able to answer it first time around
but it's just that
approach of actually included me in the
conversations instead of doing
punishment to me I should have been
doing it with me I ended up being
diagnosed with
ADHD um
you know like mild autism spectrum and
stuff like that
and when you heard that where you're
like oh right that's something or will
you just say I don't grow again this is
the The Point again is it wasn't
explained to me it wasn't done with me
it wasn't oh so this is how this is what
this means
there's all these amazing people out
there that have ADHD but are able to
express themselves healthily you know
this is some of the resources and tools
that they use to keep themselves safe or
to manage their
symptoms or whatever
it was just oh
well it seemed like it was just a tick
boxing exercise so that
schools and whoever else could go okay
that's why I can't control him okay yeah
that's what it seemed like to me it
still feels like that was the case
I never go also what's meant to happen
then so you're out of school but what
how are you meant to continue your kind
of progress through education are you
meant to do it at home after that or
what's the well then they're trying to
get me into different schools right
um
because my gcses already kind of started
not many schools wanted to um let me in
so I was at school for about a year then
got into a school for my got into a new
school for my last year of Education
but I'd already been out on the streets
for a year throughout year 10
by that point and was told that I had
these labels I had no understanding of
so I was just like [ __ ] it then if
you're going to tell me that I've got
these problems and those problems mean
that I can't learn
then why am I going to try so then it
became a useful excuse
and you said before that when you're
younger you weren't aggressive was that
was aggression starting to manifest in
you that was starting to manifest in me
just for all those reasons I guess and
then
kind of just molded me into someone who
was perfectly
situated to be groomed by
my peers and all the people on my state
and what does groomed mean in this
situation in this situation
sometimes when you think of the word
when you and someone uses the word
groomed you think
um like a deliberate like they've
groomed that person and exploited them
you know with intent
a lot of the time I feel like me and my
friends groomed each other
in the beliefs and the values that we
had in terms of that's interesting
street code right in terms of
well this is like the most controversial
one which is like snitching which is you
know it's you know you don't do it
um
although
now
you know in my in my story later on
people have snitched on me and I've
forgiven them
and I don't
I don't think that's a
a useful
value to hold
um especially if it means that you're
going to go to prison for 20 30 years
for someone else
but where are these rules coming from
are they being generated within your
group are they coming down from older
people who are coming in there it's a
bit of both it's the group
and their families
and then the wider Community as well see
in this position
um as you're describing very eloquently
how long is it
before the event that we're going to
spend quite a lot of time talking about
uh so I'm about 16 17 now the event
happens not long into my 19th birthday
um so we're
a couple of years down the line really
um so not far at all
and I guess what happens around this
time as well
is I started experimenting more with
drinking
and then a little bit later on as I
started getting introduced to some more
older
people
um cocaine as well
and that's when the violence just
went off the scale because I've got all
that unprocessed anger as to you know
who I even am and where I fit in in the
world and what I'm ever going to amount
to
um
and then it's all coming out when I'm
getting drunk and it's all coming out in
all my makes as well and did you like it
at that point did it feel like a thrill
it was the adrenaline rush it's just
like it was like oh Friday night didn't
have no money we're gonna end up like
you know a couple of us chipping in for
a big bottle of vodka yeah yeah
[ __ ]
yeah it was it was a it was a mess to be
honest but you know there's always a
couple of you in the group who would
start a fight or they'll just run up
someone and
start punching them and did you get
beaten up at those points as well or was
it more like you were running into
things and getting away sort of Mischief
so yeah it was Mischief stuff but I was
getting um
yeah I was gonna getting bottled and God
it's quite terrifying the way the
violence is quickly spiraling out from
some Lads messing about yeah playing
computer games or whatever and then
hanging around the state and suddenly
it's like the violence has appeared
you're making enemies everywhere you go
in
and people remember who you are and
stuff like that so it's like
you've stood outside a bar and then next
thing you know
well when you when you're describing you
know rules around not being snitches and
all that kind of thing it's building a
situation where the community you have
is is the bond that you've got and
everyone outside that is basically not
part of it yeah yeah so it's for you to
say oh don't do that to that guy none of
us know yeah
it could be seen as a good trainers
aren't yeah almost a betrayal of like oh
they won't trust you yeah they'll be
like oh you're not joining in or they
won't invite you out next time and do
you think when you're talking about you
having uh unprocessed anger is what you
said do you think that's what your mates
had too but for different reasons or do
you think they some of them just enjoyed
it and some of them were just going
through a weird growth period or do you
think that a lot of you had issues that
was making it making violence appear
yeah I think a lot of us had issues like
that I think the majority of us
didn't have office around or that were
present in our lives we'd all failed in
school just being kicked out of school
or not getting any GCS either and stuff
like that
can be quite shameful you know no one's
Really Got Each of his best interests
because you're all actually trying to
make each other do more risful things or
put each other in more Harm's Way
um
so yeah sometimes I feel like we don't
actually we say that we're brothers and
that will ride
or die poor
yeah you're just going to put me in the
grave quicker to be honest
and I wish someone had to kind of open
my eyes to that a little bit earlier on
in the relationship with your mum what
was that like at that point
the rest of my mom was very strained
because she didn't know what to she
didn't know how to manage me
and um it had gone on for so long that I
kind of just
doing whatever I wanted really that's
one of my biggest regrets
is the way I treated her from a teenage
years because she was the only one that
actually had my back
well it sounds like you're saying in the
kind of like
in the chronology of your life is that
the night that the event happened
doesn't seem like it would have been
anything out of the ordinary
yeah
it was an ordinary day even the event
itself you're talking about walking
around town but can we get into that
yeah yeah how that happened so um it was
my mate's birthday
and
he was one of the youngest in the group
between 18. so we were like oh yes you
can finally finally come out with us you
know what I mean he was like born in
August I think which is like the end of
the
yeah there was a big massive group of us
and um
I remember as we're walking to town
there was people in the group saying
stuff like
basically we're all going to get into a
fight tonight
that would be be common unfortunately as
we were excited about it yeah like
excited about it if anyone started on us
a lot
you know what I mean you know you're all
freaking a bit drunk and you're
just acting a bit stupid
went to quite a few bars because it was
such a big group of us
and you're all young and don't know how
to handle your drink we all ended up
scattered all over the city center
which was common and then we'd usually
all meet up
like two three in the morning but yeah
we was all
mingling around
um
and I actually got a sorry I weren't
mingling around so my friends were
mingling around and they called and they
start getting into trouble
so they called me I was in a bar that
was still just closing on
and um
me being the person that I am and the
values that we just talked about that I
had back then
they wanted my help they said that there
was trouble starting so
can you um obviously come and help us
out
so me being the person that I was
instantly just went running down to
where they were
didn't ask
what are you not even doing like who are
you arguing with why are you arguing
I did see one of my friends
who was like squaring off with someone
but I think he was being the aggressor
my friend was being the aggressor
and then
he got pulled away I can remember
rightly and then I
just decided that it was my
responsibility
to hit that person and throw a punch at
that person
and then
I ran away
um straight away because I kind of I
didn't really know what happened but I
knew that he'd like fell to the ground
so um my instant reaction was
to just make a run for it because I was
in the middle of
Nottingham City Center so I just ran
away
you know realizing I think what I
realized that in that moment
is that I didn't actually want to hurt
the guy I was just throwing a punch
for like credit from my friends or to
just make a point
in front of my friends
my friends came around the next day and
um
knocked on for me at my mom's house
I came to the bathroom window I looked
out down and um
they were like oh yes Jacob
um like one punch like you're not that
guy at one point remember
um like basically
boost in my ego and trying to like give
me praise
um so at this point did you have any
guilt towards it more just like yeah the
night ended well I've like done all this
stuff my friends think I'm a legend yeah
well I think by the next morning I just
thought oh
because I've seen that many fires
and Bin
punched or bottled and knocked over
myself or whatever that
um it was all just a bit of a
bit of a
bit of a laugh
and then I guess there's a window from
then
to when I actually found out what
happened
and that window was about a month
I think it's about two weeks later my
mum had already booked had booked as a
week's holiday in Tenerife
um
which I guess was my last family holiday
I had with my little brother and um my
mum
and it was actually really nice it was
like one of the first times in a long
time where it was just me my mum we're
not in the Meadows we're in a different
country
and I kind of I guess it it started to
make me realize a little bit
about taking it for granted
um in the Years previously
and we were in this Hotel in Tenerife
watching the London riots and my mom was
like oh I'm glad
you're not in the UK because
you'd probably end up joining that
wouldn't you I was just like oh I don't
know I was watching I was like blocking
out it's going crazy back in the UK
um
and obviously the rights did spread to
Nottingham Manchester Birmingham and
wherever else it spread to
which is important to know because when
I got back from Tenerife
I can't remember how long it was but it
wasn't long and the police raided
my mom's house I wasn't in
but when they raided the house they were
going through all my closed drawers and
like going through all my kind of
belongings and everything
and so my mum thought oh they think
he's part of the right Nottingham riots
because they're looking for clothes all
right cool stolen goods or whatever it
is
and my friends were like calling me and
saying that lots of lots of my friends
who I was out with that night a month
earlier they were all being arrested
but it hadn't got to me what they were
actually being arrested for
I ended up finding out
just as the police
well basically the police called
my um
the police called me off my mum's
phone number oh right when they were in
the house so you saw your mum's phone
number yeah I answered it what was the
landline number anyone uses landlines
anymore
so I've answered it and um
it's like oh it's the police I'm like oh
my God
and like oh can you just come and hand
yourself in that the police station
please
um you got nothing to worry about
we're just following up on an
investigation
I kind of had a sense then by this point
what
what supposedly happened
so I went down to the police station to
actually find out for sure what was
actually going on
and because going on the run or whatever
was
pointless
um so I went and handed myself in at the
police station
and that's when um
that's when I found out that um I was
being arrested
for murder and that that punch that I
threw
had led
to James's um
death
because it not necessarily from the
punch itself because he'd fell back and
um hit his head got us fracture on the
score and had passed away
I think it was seven or nine days later
in hospital from
those injuries
I feel disrespectful sometimes saying
the man that I punched but at the same
time I don't know whether
to refer to him
that really sometimes as I'm talking
about these things sometimes I just
don't know what the right yeah by his
name
um
you know I don't want to be insensitive
to anyone I'm sure it could defend
someone either way whether I do or I
don't
because I want to honor him everything
I've done
has been to
you know honor him
how do you process that age because
you've gone from having a holiday that
you really enjoyed starting to rebuild a
relationship with your mum come back not
sure what's going on and then basically
being arrested for probably the most
serious crime um
what what was going on
to be honest it was just pure panic
anxiety
unimaginable levels of stress
and um
just felt like a constant panic attack
to be honest like a prolonged panic
attack
I guess at that point I was trying not
to think about
the person that had punched in their
family just because like my world was
crumbling down and I don't think I had
the ability
to even
think about
other people at that moment
and how does it work with say telling
your mom that the police call her and
tell her or do you have to call her and
tell her
well what happened they kept me in the
police cells
um
for as long as they're allowed
but they still weren't wasn't sure
whether it was me or someone else that
threw the punch did you remember at this
point I remembered at this point yeah
um
but they still weren't sure whether it
was me or
more of a friend who had been arrested
for the same charge
so while they were still Gathering
evidence because they still had like
witnesses to go and find and other
friends that they hadn't found yet
um
so they released me on bail for a day
and I went back home and I sat down on
the sofa with my mum
it was obviously like
she was a charminder
yeah for like the last 10 15 years of
her life
um
was a really good child minder
but all the devices have been taken out
the house and
that the home house was upside down and
whatever else
she was just like what have you done
Jacob what have you done and she always
used to think again you know how I
mentioned in school she'd come up with
um
an excuse for him here or something
um and she'd be like oh you're not
covering up for your mate sorry yeah you
know and just like telling me to like
tell the truth or whatever
um
and then the local BBC East Midlands
news came on
and they said two men from The Meadows
they've been arrested
on suspicion to murder
and I was just like she was like she
just looked at me and said
that's not you is it
and that's how she found out
she didn't take it very well at all
she was like
freaking out
convinced that I didn't do it convinced
that I was covering up for my mates
the next day
they had gathered some more of my
friend's statements
and then they'd been they'd found all
the girls that were out that night and
they'd like been invaded their houses
and got interviews of all of them
and so now there was quite a few
statements saying
that it was me that did it
how did that feel because at that point
in time as you discussed earlier you had
this big thing around no snitching
so this has happened and your friendship
group is starting to did you see that as
snitching as you can yeah yeah of course
I was like
fuming yeah I had the statements I was
walking around my neighborhood
to all the
so-called
manam and
saying look at what these men have been
writing
they're all snitches and what were
people saying
well some of them were just like oh
I'm not really interested which made me
think well
what what have I been believing in um
and other people were
bereaved and angry about it
but I was having to be in my house my
mom's house from seven o'clock
and um
with a woman that was slowly losing her
mind
with the news that she'd been told about
her son and his inevitable
trip to prison
um
and I was losing my mind just living
with her and I couldn't leave the house
it already felt like I was in prison to
be honest and by that time I was on
attack for two months waiting sentencing
I think I had to get my bill
tag address moved to a friend's house
because it had become
so
toxic living at home wow
um
and because I was basically saying to
the police Lord we just take me to
prison now I'm going to breach my
conditions
um
now I'd rather just get this over with
and not be in limbo
and were you pleading guilty or not
guilty yeah well I um pled guilty
when it was dropped to manslaughter and
when there was overwhelming up until
that point I was just following my
solicitors advice that
you know you're saying nothing until
you presented with being presented with
whatever evidence there is in what's
happened
but unfortunately because of that
snitching element of the evidence
I was I still wasn't taking
accountability
I was still more interested in
I guess I felt like a victim was an
element as well in there because I guess
it wasn't your fight right you didn't to
help your friend you'd run across town
to help your friends it was it was an
element of like I did this for you and
now you've [ __ ] me over basically yeah
in ways yeah
and I guess all of that in itself
challenged
my view of
the culture that I had put all my eggs
in
and he continued to when I went into
custody because
you know then you think that your
friend's gonna write to you or they're
going to visit you
or or whatever and you just realized
that
we're actually all just enabling each
other
um
we're not actually a good friends we
don't actually care
do I mean as long as you're around to go
out on a weekend
that's as deep as the relationship
really goes so you were taken so you you
came to a trial time gave your trial
after did you say two months it took
yeah two months two months and then I
went for sentencing as you say yeah
um
went to court
not knowing what to expect myself is
telling me you could should expect for
months or one punch manslaughter or
anywhere from
what's it about
two and a half to
six seven years or something like that
um
so in my mind I was like right I'm I'm
getting six years
or whatever
um trying to just mentally prepare
myself
because I've never been prison
didn't really know what to expect
although I had a lot of friends and
olders in my area that had and they were
all like
make sure you plug as much drugs as you
can make sure you were
don't let no one take you through a
[ __ ]
are you scared which is all kind of
quite daunting yeah I mean like
because I come from a good home
non-criminal
background home do you know what I mean
without any males in my family either I
was raised by my mum her twin sister and
my my nun
so other than the friendships I had
hadn't really been exposed as much as
some of my other friends too
some of these parts of this life um
and so yeah it was very daunting I
wouldn't have admitted it at the time of
course and even when I was in prison or
just after come out of prison I wouldn't
have admitted it but now
that's a grown man
I'm not afraid to admit
um when I've done wrong let alone when
I've when I'm when I've been scared in
the past
yeah very daunting
I'm just not knowing what to expect and
then I knew that the family of the man I
punched were in the courtroom as well
so when I got into the courtroom I just
kind of I just sat in the dock and just
looked at my feet
I didn't dare make eye contact with
anyone because I didn't know who was who
and you said you'd prepared in your mind
for six years what was the sentence in
the end in the end I got the lowest
which was two and a half years
um but because I was so absent in the
courtroom
um
I didn't even know how long ago I got
took down to um
to the Holdings I was getting ready to
go in the sweatbox to prison
and uh I had to ask the one of the
guards I said oh how long did I get and
they said oh I think you've got 30
months two and a half years
I was
I don't want to say happy but
I was relieved I guess that it was the
lower half of that
um
there was still a part of me that was
like well I've still got to do the still
got to do the time I still gotta go to
prison I don't know what to expect
um
just one day at a time was my mentality
to take one day at a time
and what was it like in prison
is that being back in school
to be honest
it's like no one's grown up
and no one has because they've all got
kicked out of school
and then
cover them you know vaguely speaking
with the same
Class Clown Antics and
you know
easily offended always
looking for drama
was it threatening yeah it was
definitely threatening it was like
school but more hostile that makes sense
it's like
everyone had grown up but they still had
that kind of kitty mentality
but everyone was grown up and much more
willing to use violence now and at that
point
did you how did you feel in yourself
like did you feel angry did you feel sad
did you feel like you like you said
earlier you felt like a victim like what
was your kind of feeling about yourself
and your role in it
well unfortunately if anyone asked me in
prison what I did I'd tell them what I
did but then
I'll tell them that
the reason I was in prison was because
someone snitched on me when people
snitched on me
and then I just knew instantly because I
already know what their values are
that they're just going to reinforce my
values
so I was never going to be held
accountable by anyone in there
because the way I told my story
which is the opposite to what I'm doing
today
is um
yeah well I used to just minimize
and not take care of you if any anything
I did and
emphasize
any areas where I could defer that
accountability to somebody else
and because I was in a cohort of people
in prison
where they all have those same negative
values and
you know criminal mindsets
which is sometimes why I think well you
know how do you expect people to change
and take responsibility in prison when
they're surrounded by people we hold
unhealthy
ways of thinking and on top of that
you're told when to get up
you're giving your meals
you're stripped of all responsibility
in in the regime
and you stripped of any
people around you that could try and
Foster some responsibility within you
so I think it's probably the worst place
to send someone although I don't want to
come up here and tell you that there's a
better option but what I would say is
that it is the worst place
to send someone if you want them to
State responsibility were you letting
guilt in at this point or were you kind
of closing all out yeah because even
though it's interesting when you said
you'd say you're in prison because
people snitched not in prison because of
the action that caused a snitching yeah
exactly yeah so I'm still not wanting to
take accountability and there's only one
time
in the whole
um
of my prison sentence
where I was offered a window to take
responsibility
there was two attempts by the prison
well there's only one where I actually
did
and the one where I actually did was um
it was on the anniversary
of James's death and the vicar from the
chaplain
without me knowing came to come and let
me out of my
prison cell and reminded me that it was
that day and asked me if I wanted to go
somewhere quiet
to like say a prayer
yeah I went down
to the chaplain which is away from the
prison wing and wherever else
and it was just
that was the first time I was able to
think about him without
instantly
dismissing it out of my mind
yeah my mom used to take me to church
all the time when I was little until I
was old enough to say no yeah
um
that I'm not necessarily practicing
person of Faith now although I live my
life
as if I was if that makes sense you know
but yeah he offered that kind of safe
space
without kind of trying to shame me
so what led to am I right in thinking
you went through like a restorative
justice is that how it said restorative
justice yeah what is it a system or a
process I'd say yeah it's either a
process or a conference okay
um can you explain what it is exactly
yeah so
I got out of prison
in about two months
after
I couldn't move back in with my mum
um so I was like sorry for surfing
because of your relationship I was that
part of the because of our relationship
right and
yeah just for like various reasons
really I was like I just want to try and
get on my own feet
obviously I didn't have any
qualifications
that never CV
didn't have any fixed address didn't
have an email address didn't have a bank
account
um
and so it's just like I'm a probation
officers
um office trying to get as much support
as I could in those first couple of
months
and then
two months after getting out I went to
go see my probation officer and she said
Jacob have you ever heard of something
called restorative justice
and I was like
no what is that
and then she basically told me that
it's where
a victim and a perpetrator or you could
say someone that's been harmed and
someone must commit the harm
get brought together
to have a conversation about
you know what happened between you two
between those parties
and that is voluntary it has to be
voluntary from both parties to enter
into it
um and that the
the parents of James
had requested to
make contact with me and whether I was
open to speaking with them as part of
this restorative justice
process
I went away for a week I didn't want to
make like a rush decision
I said I think about it and um
it wasn't something I necessarily wanted
to do but it was something that
it felt like the right thing to do
I felt like
it almost like felt like I had some sort
of power over
them because I had
answers to questions that they had
and I was the only person that had them
and I didn't want to
hold that over them
you know the story you've told up until
now is you know sounds like a you know
when we've heard a lot about a young
angry man's you know feels attacked by
the world
it surprises me that you'd come to that
conclusion I know I know I think
I think there was always something there
that wanted me to find a Lifeline um
I don't think I was going to benefit
from it I just felt like
it was the least I could do
and whether it would help them or not I
don't know but I was just like well
if you're telling me that they have
questions and I'm the only one that can
answer them
then
I don't want to be walking around with
them and not
not offering that
back to them that's the least I can do
surely
from the start though they said that
they weren't willing to
speak to me face to face like straight
away
and they said that
that maybe consider
meeting me face to face in 10 years time
which would have been around now hmm
but that they
wanted
to First just ask me some questions
because what happened like like written
questions yeah written down questions so
what they did is they would ask them
loads of
questions the practitioners and get lots
of information from them
then they'll come to me once I said yes
with those questions
and present them to me
and um
it was things like
I don't know had I ever
done like boxing or any martial arts
training
questions around what happened that
night
had he spilled a drink on me or
looked at my girl or yeah I mean all the
other you know what people think are
normal reasons for fighting which are
normal reasons for fighting
and that's when uh
I had to come to terms
with um
as we've already mentioned the reason
why I did actually do it and I felt so
ashamed telling them
that
I
punched this on because
my friends had
called me up
and I didn't really know why
I had
I had no excuse basically
we continued like that for about six
months just passing back and forth
through the mediators
um
our conversations and correspondence and
what's also important to note is that
the parents did
in some way have a more punitive
response to me initially
because they had appealed
to the courts and to the
the government
for me to get a harsher sentence but
because the judge had given me a
sentence that was within the sentencing
guidelines
um it got refused
and so when they went back to their like
police liaison officer support officer
and that was rejected
he the this police officer said well
this is the only Direction I can think
of is the story of Justice
I don't know if he'll say yes to it or
whether you would get anything from it
or if anybody will get anything from it
but that is an option and that's when
they considered going down this
restorative justice which is sitting
around the table and using dialogue as a
way of resolving your emotions and
things that you ruminated about
once I'd answered all their questions
they
I guess they then
didn't want me to in an Ideal World
to con just answer all their questions
and then just carry on
living the life that I was living that
wouldn't have been
Justice
that would have been a waste of my life
and and everything else so
they started to ask me questions like
what are you going to do with your life
and I was completely unprepared for
those questions
I was like oh my gosh because remember
when I first went into it I only wanted
to do it to help yeah them you know I
wasn't really thinking about me gaining
anything from this or moving on in a
positive way
what if they want me to do it
then
no one else's opinion should matter
I mean no someone says because my
friends would be like oh because I I
what I ended up telling them is that I
was going to try and do my gcses again
it was like 21 22 now
and
I said well
well I don't know what I can do but
maybe I'll have another shot on my gcses
against I'm a probation officer helped
me
start trying to do my gcses again
and um
what I realized is that
okay so people that are at home the most
were the ones that were judging me the
least
quite a long story short I ended up
getting an a star in English an a star
in psychology
and I got a CM Mass which was I was very
proud of
and all of a sudden I loved education I
could not believe that I was sitting
there
passionate about education and actually
being able to learn new information
actually reading a book I read my first
book when I went and did my gcses The
Great Gatsby and I was still
corresponding with David and Joan but it
was just at this point I was just saying
to them
I'll keep you posted on how my studies
go because I answered all their
questions I didn't really want much
else from me in that respect
just other than can you keep us posted
on how you're doing and
you progress
um
and so yeah when I finish My GCSE I
write wrote them a letter and I was just
like
you know I've done this you know
um I'm gonna my plan is to do my I need
an access course after that in higher
education
in social sciences
and like I passed that with distinctions
and then within two years I was in a
position to
go to university
any anybody course I wanted really and
um
I wrote to them to tell them that I was
planning on I wanted to do social work
I want to be a social worker and um
yeah I played to a few universities to
study social work because my criminal
records
I was like rejected
from all the universities and I was like
oh my God like I'd be amazing social
workers not enough men in social work
anyway
and
I know the a lot of the the issues
I didn't really know what backup course
to pick so I picked criminology I'm like
well live the life of crime up until
this point been in prison
maybe if I'm going to start campaigning
around some of these issues if I go and
study criminology I can attach my lived
experience with a
theoretical wouldn't hang in as well
um that put me in a good position to
commentate going forward or whatever
and so I told them I was going to study
criminology
and that's when
they got back in touch through the
mediators practitioners
um
that they were ready to meet me
face to face
and this was two and a half years from
that first bit of Correspondence two and
a half years
and I guess it was because of the work
that I'd done in that two and a half
years
and then
the things I had achieved in that short
space of time that they felt
they could trust me so they felt
comfortable
um meeting me face to face at this point
and uh
and then we arranged to me face to face
which was
surreal hmm
I can't even imagine what you talk about
now first meeting
well what we did do is um
because up until that point we'd had
these conversations
through practitioners yeah through
mediation so we did it all again right
but face to face
so the whole from the beginning all the
original no not exactly the original
questions but
them telling me
how what happened to them has affected
them
so in terms of like
funeral and
you know all that kind of stuff so
now I was there
it was important for them to be able to
say to my face yeah so what I mean and
um
I guess I wanted to hear it as well
oh I needed to hear it
yeah what is that meeting and
I arrived there
and these are like awkward Smiles by the
way no no I get it but um you said to me
and also because it was it was a good
well it was a really difficult
experience
it was also a life-changing experience
as well that
but you said to me outside about how
people sometimes pick up how you react
and make comments on it but I think we'd
meet so many people who've lived so many
complex experiences and the thing is
like you just can't it's not the film
it's not the movies where there's a way
of reacting like humans react in ways
that they can't always predict
um it's something that's clear uh so I
get what you're saying that sometimes
when people smile I have the reaction is
not connected to happiness sometimes it
might be but often it can be awkwardness
or shock or yeah so but please carry on
the practitioners that we kind of knew
really well by this point because
they've been on this journey with us for
the whole time oh the same ones yeah
same ones
um
it's important to keep right the same
ones just so that you can
carry through everything and
and
um
they was at either side
and then they told me
you know to my face
what James was like as a person or his
personality was like the things he
enjoyed doing in life
um
again the impact that he had on them and
their family
um
and I was I didn't really quite know
what to do I was just I was just taking
it all in obviously what like I find it
really hard to like make eye contact
with them and I was like
tearing up and um
but again I wanted to hear it because
sometimes you can hide
behind
not knowing
and so you don't never take
responsibility because you never knew
the true impact
of how you made other people feel
you're hearing it all again two and a
half years later
from them sat across the table from me
was um
a surreal experience and kind of just
cemented why I was doing exactly what I
was doing up until that point
um and then
once they'd covered that
we move the conversation towards you
know how I was getting on over the last
couple of years
what my hopes were for University
and then we agreed in that meeting that
we wanted to raise awareness together
that a single punch can kill
what's your relationship like now with
the parents of James
as things stand
um it's a little bit like
how it's always been really in terms of
me
keeping them posted on
you know life and maybe quarterly or
yearly or whatever just feels
appropriate from my point of view
um
but my email or phone is always open for
them but I feel like I'm a little bit
more hesitant the other way around if
that makes sense like
I
won't communicate more than I feel that
I need to
but
I'm always open for any correspondence
from them if that makes sense
it's so interesting talking to you
because
obviously it wasn't one single thing but
if you know from the beginning of the
conversation it feels like a lot of your
issues and challenges early on were sort
of triggered by education and in fact
everyone's going through a single system
and you fell out on the outside of it
kept getting excluded playing up thought
you couldn't do it because of your
diagnosis but the way you talk is so
you know you sound like a very
intelligent person
when you speak and it's that kind of
thing where it feels like there's a bit
of tragedy in the fact that if you've
been in a different position it might
have all been so different and that's
why I'm so passionate about
what it is that I talk about because in
essence it is all just communication
you know about the communication between
the teachers and me communication
between me and my mum communication
between me and my dad or absence of it
um
it took for lots of tragedy to happen
and then for me to have good healthy
communication with the people I'd harm
the most for me to start learning how to
communicate myself
I mean we did we did a video before
together
um
with lad Bible and yourself and um
I think as a team we were all quite
struck by the positivity in the comments
because I think what that video did was
when you read the title and you go into
it you go into it with a massive
assumption about what that person is who
could do that kind of thing and you go
on the journey and you just realize that
you know one of the comments I saw that
stood out to me is that you've got a
life sentence in a sense yeah you can
see that it helped you know it's a big
weight on you still when you talk about
it
and
a lot of young people there were a lot
of comments in there as well where young
people are saying like God this guy
should come and talk to me and my mates
and all that kind of thing and we have a
big youth audience
what is it that you want to communicate
to young people watching this who can
see themselves in the position that you
were in just before the event that
ultimately changed the direction of your
life
don't look don't wait for your lives to
become tragic
before you make better decisions
foreign
84 charges they wanted to arrest me for
because they made each separate hack a
charge right if you want to charge you
84 times they have to arrest you 84
times and then that means they have to
caution you 84 times but they only did
it for half the charges for 40 of the
charges because they could only hold me
for 24 hours